richard branson el fundador de virgin
galactic ha cumplido su sueño de ir al
espacio lo ha hecho este domingo en el
vuelo juniti 22 y acompañado de otras
cinco personas tras esta experiencia
según el única y mágica que ha durado
unos 60 minutos aproximadamente el
magnate británico ha dicho estar
convencido de que en poco tiempo los
viajes turísticos serán una realidad a
pesar de que el vuelo ha arrancado una
hora y media más tarde por problemas con
el clima unas 300 personas se han
congregado en esta pista de aterrizaje
para seguir minuto a minuto la travesía
hasta llegar a la estratosfera el
momento más esperado ha sido cuando el
aparato después de triplicar la
velocidad del sonido ha alcanzado la
ingravidez a unos 80 kilómetros de
altura antes de iniciar su descenso a la
tierra tras esta gesta todos han
empezado a aplaudir consciente del hito
histórico que suponía y también porque
branson encabeza ahora la carrera por
los viajes espaciales de hecho él
adelantó la fecha de su aventura después
de que jett de esos el fundador de
amazon anunciara que iría al espacio con
un aparato de
a blue origin aunque branson insiste en
que esto no es una carrera lo cierto es
que él no quería que ni besos ni almas
fueran antes que él especialmente porque
los ingenieros de la compañía llevan
casi dos décadas trabajando arduamente
en este proyecto con todo el empresario
del reino unido- ha acabado
convirtiéndose en la primera persona en
llegar a la estratosfera gracias a un
proyecto financiado por sí mismo virgin
galactic ha confirmado que sus planes
pasan ahora por empezar a enviar
turistas al espacio a partir del próximo
año la compañía dice que ya hay más de
600 personas que están en lista de
espera para hacer lo mismo que ha hecho
richard branson este mismo domingo un
viaje que cuesta alrededor de 250 mil
dólares